my name is margaret neal
i go by maggie and i am the adams
distinguished professor of management
at the graduate school of business at
stanford university
i teach courses in negotiation and
managing teams and
my research is in the area of
negotiation
and managing teams what i'm really
interested in
as a research topic and in what i teach
is
how people create value that is
the study of synergy how can you and i
be more than just you plus me
and what i'm interested in is how can
that synergy that is created
make me better off as an individual make
my team better off
and make the organization in which that
team is embedded
better off i have a master's in hospital
pharmacy administration
and while i was taking courses there i
discovered psychology
and was wowed by it
so i spent some time in my master's
degree in pharmacy
taking psychology courses and by the
time i finished that master's degree i
realized
i wanted to be in the area of psychology
and not in the area of pharmacy
i went for my phd in organizational
behavior at the university of texas
completed that and then took my first
faculty position
at the university of arizona in tucson
it was at the eller school
i got tenure there and i also got tenure
at the kellogg school and i chose to go
to the kellogg school
at northwestern university in chicago i
was there
until 1995 where i joined stanford
i've been exceedingly happy with my time
here at stanford
this is a great place so many smart
people
and those smart people are the students
those smart people are the faculty
those smart people are the staff you're
surrounded by people who are
interesting and engaged in the creation
of knowledge and the dissemination of
that knowledge
and that is such an important thing
[Music]
you